langsam scheint sich das rätsel um die
getötete tabitha zu lösen bild
-informationen war die 17 jährige
schülerin aus asperg bei ludwigsburg
offenbar kein zufallsopfer
sie ist das opfer eines brutalen mordes
in der nähe von ludwigsburg
der tatverdächtige ein 35 jähriger syrer
wohl mindestens ein guter bekannter
tabitha die
schülerin verlässt am dienstag ihr
elternhaus und erzählte dass sie mit dem
bus nach ludwigsburg fahren und dort
stoppen wolle sie kommt nie zurück die
polizei sucht mit hubschrauber drohnen
und suchhunden etablierter
schwerpunkt der aktion ein waldstück
beim wasserturm in markgröningen am lzh
bachtal
dann der schock die leiche wird gefunden
sie liegt am klärwerk beutelsbach am
gefahr eines flusses getötet und
weggeworfen
die wohnung des tatverdächtigen syrers
wird durchsucht seinem bmw beschlagnahmt
in dem auch tabitha gesessen haben
könnte und ein richter erließ haftbefehl
die beweise scheinen er drückt den
umstand der tötung ist noch gegenstand
der ermittlungen
da können wir noch keine weiteren
angaben dazu machen auch wo sie
umgebracht wurde wissen wir derzeit noch
nicht wir können wir kennen lediglich
den ablageort der leiche und erst wie
bereits erwähnt an der enz gewesen der
35 jährige sitzt nun in u haft und
schwingend
männliche syrer die ihre partnerinnen
ermorden immer wieder das gleiche tat
musste
november letzten jahres eine frau wird
auf der a 7 bei schließt weg von einem
lastwagen tödlich im barock
doch dem unglück ging wohl ein
gewaltverbrechen ist das opfer weist
mindestens 24 messerstecher
der 34-jährige syrische ehemann steht
unter mordverdacht er habe seine frau am
20 november
2021 aus niedrigen beweggründen getötet
sagt die staatsanwältin weiter anklage
verlesen er habe aus gekränkter ehre und
aus rache beschlossen die 32-jährige uns
im november 2020 massakriert der
pizzakurier seine 20 jährige mohammed 31
messerstichen
die tat geschieht im auto vor den augen
der drei kinder war hieß es glaubt dass
seine frau ihn betrügt
noch am tatort überwältigt in die
polizei
der richter sagt wahrheit handelt aus
einem tief hat die archaischen er
verständnis
märz 2018 ein 42 jähriger syrischer
flüchtlinge ersticht in mühlacker seine
von ihm getrenntlebende
der mörder wird zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt das motiv sei bestrafung und
rache betont der vorsitzende richter
weil sich seine syrische ehefrau einem
anderen mann zugewandt habe der mörder
veröffentlicht auf der flucht noch ein
handy-video rechtfertigt darin seine tat
zurück in die gegenwart und jetzt
tabitha mit 17 jahren hatte sie noch ihr
ganzes leben für sie
[Musik]